hi I'm Eric box and we have a third new
trailer for spider-man homecoming and
because we apparently can't get enough
of these we also have a separate new
international trailer that also came out
and between both of these trailers
there's actually a lot of new footage
with a ton of interesting details so I'm
going to go through and break down all
the new stuff in this great domestic
trailer adding new interesting bits from
the international ones are out so let's
get started finally here we go good
evening here oh you have five hundred
only six possible shooter combinations
haha
I can keep that suit yeah something me
poisoning retreat look next mission will
call you alright it's not a hundred
grand just grab the top way alright
there yet all right kids good luck out
there ok so right away this trailer
shows off a new feature of Peters stark
design fighting suit and inner CPU with
an AI voice and an augmented reality
interface similar to the inside of iron
man's helmet now yeah at first it seemed
like this tech is a little too advanced
for a spider-man suit which
traditionally is supposed to have a more
practical DIY kind of design like
spider-man isn't Iron Man for a reason
being low-budget is part of its charm
but I think this is all part of Peters
character arc in this movie like we know
from the last trailer that star
confiscates his suit later on and played
out the way Peter says finally here it's
almost like he's been waiting all day to
play with his suit like it's a video
game that he can finally play after
finishing his homework so - Peter this
suit is like overwatch and then like
many teenage gamers Peter uses it to
start [ __ ] with adult and then father
figure Tony Stark steps in and grounds
them takes overwatch away from him and
then when Peter learns with great power
comes great whatever he becomes a man
finally and invents his own damn
overwatch see the classic coming-of-age
tale this opening section also shows us
more of Peter and Stark in the backseat
and I feel like we've seen so many
pieces of the scene in each trailer and
that could mean that they actually shot
a lot of alternate dialogue and jokes
for the scene like you may have noticed
in recent years that trailers had
included slightly different dialogue
than the versions of these scenes in the
final theatrical release nowadays
directors will shoot some takes solely
for the marketing people who assemble
the trailers like remember that shot of
Jen or so in the first rogue one teaser
- eh it's Gareth Edwards apparently God
just like Ellie and Felicity Jones name
on set and recording her reaction go
Felicity we got to make a trailer anyway
I know I obsess over the exact footage
that are in these trailers but I'm just
keeping my fingers crossed that this
movie will feel new and surprising when
we see it in theatres cool let's move on
big eater going tonight I can't tonight
I got the start internship what's up
guys here's my report for tonight I
stopped the grandstand flight school hey
could you do me a favor Polana I helped
this old lady and she bought me a churro
so how was nice okay here we see some
more shots of Peter as a typical high
school nerd that we saw in past trailers
but also a few new examples of him as a
local friendly neighborhood spider-man
catching a bike thief and bragging that
an old lady bottom a churro and what I
like most about this is how not a big
deal spider-man is like notice how he's
not an Avenger level celebrity that
people are trying to take selfies with
in fact when we hear a camera snap as he
poses by the subway platform I don't see
anyone on that platform taking the photo
like this is probably just one of his
own cameras that he rigged up ahead of
time to take pictures of himself so this
is just such a funny grounded total
choice for the movie like even as a
superhero with a really cool suit he's
still a loser Hey look at me let me save
you meanwhile all these jaded New
Yorkers are just like oh wow this little
loser thinks these old metal face and a
green fatty and I get out of here like
even Tony Stark won't take his calls he
just leaves these voicemails documenting
the friendly neighborhoods [ __ ] that
he did that day that starts probably
never even listening to now the
International trailer actually opens
with Peter keeping these geeky records
in a totally different way vlogging
shooting behind the scenes footage of
the airport battle and Civil War it also
shows him gushing about it in the hotel
room afterward as happy interruption and
notice here that the web shooters that
Peter is wearing on his wrist look
different from the web shooters that we
saw him wearing under his clothes and
Captain America Civil War these of
course are the new Tony Stark upgraded
one with 576 different web shooter
combinations
he's probably going to wear these all
the time just a Peter be a little
careful that you don't wear them out now
the question I have about all this is if
Peter wants to keep his identity secret
why is the vlogging about this stuff
with his mask off so I guess this could
be like a private video journal that he
keeps for himself but I have a theory
that he could be making these videos to
confide all these amazing experiences
with someone maybe his deceased uncle
been like this is how he keeps his
memory alive or maybe Peter just thinks
when people die they live in computers
let's move on I just wish I could be
doing more wait a minute you guys on the
real event just hope gives it away you
move them working on some bad
he's working for crazy dangerous ok so
here we see more of this spoiled ATM
robbery and more of the advanced tech
that these criminals are using this
weapon looks kind of like the gravity
gun from half-life 2 and we start to see
how this repurposed advanced weaponry is
becoming a problem in this movie like
this guy totally loses control the laser
as it slices through the entire block
and we learned that that's what causes
the deli to explode so the International
trailer actually goes into more of the
background on this it includes a shot of
Michael Keaton character Adrienne to
miss the vulture and he look closely at
the shot this is in New York's Grand
Central Station probably shortly after
the Battle of New York and Avengers 2
minutes is hacking away at a Chitauri
area and in the background you can see a
dead Leviathan actually this is probably
the same Leviathan brought down by Hulk
and soar in that battle so I'm guessing
that this footage is from a flashback
showing how to miss and his crew
acquired all the tech they're the guys
who show up to clean up whatever big
Avengers conflict and then gather all
the scraps left behind by Atari
Ultron's minions Hydra controlled
helicarriers and then they use those
scraps to build new weapons that they
can't really control so like civil war
this movie is using the consequences of
past events in the MCU to establish the
conflict of this film which is a really
economical way to crap a story alright
let's move on mr. fader tell people who
handled this sort of thing can't you
just be a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
okay so a few really interesting things
here first there's this shot of Peter as
he watches start take off in a jet from
Avengers HQ and check out this Avengers
logo behind him framing the a and circle
behind his shoulder almost makes it look
like a number four kind of like the
Fantastic Four logo now in the past I
pointed out how this scene kind of feels
like that classic spider-man comic where
spider-man breaks into the Fantastic
Four headquarters in the comics trying
to be part of their team like I'm
wondering that Peter is now doing that
with the Avengers but this might be an
actual Fantastic Four Easter Egg here
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige has
admitted that his long-term goal is to
eventually reacquire all Marvel
properties spider-man x-men the
Fantastic Four or sinister six and
co-producing spider-man with Sony seems
like the first step in this broad Home
Coming mission so maybe if we're really
lucky sometime after the infinity war
dust settles who knows Peter Parker and
Reed Richards and Bruce Banner could go
on a really nerdy road trip together
okay next the vulture surprises
spider-man by snatching him out of this
neighborhood and I feel like this might
be the first encounter between these
characters if you look closely Peter is
clearly chasing this white van and then
it seems like the vulture is calling him
away from it so maybe this van contains
more stolen weapons parts and the
vulture doesn't want spider-man
interfering but then if you listen
closely to this part they did some cool
things with the sound mixing for one
that jet engine roars kinda sounds like
the title is ours but also when too much
looks down at Peter with these menacing
green eyes this noise that he makes is
actually the sound a real wild vulture
make listen so I just love how the sound
guys are using actual natural effects to
heighten Peters fear in this moment
alright moving on the world's changing
voice timely change too
my can't prove myself will use Spanish
Queen you gotta get better at this part
of the job I'm intimidated oh yeah okay
so some big things to point out here one
I like the Joker Ned that Peter
shouldn't save the world because they
have a Spanish quiz again it seems like
this movie is gonna be really good at
grounding Peters life as a superhero in
his mundane high school priorities and
then after more shots of him fighting
became Woodbine's character in the
school bus yard we get this quick
exchange with Miles Morales I mean
Donald Glover you gotta get better at
this part of the job I still have hope
that someday he'll cast Donald Glover as
the Morales version of spider-man but
this is interesting because it seems
here that Glover is playing a friendly
character to Peter like in the first
teaser Glover seemed to be aligned with
some of the more nefarious characters so
maybe he like switches sides to become
more of an ally to Peter or maybe just
like we saw to masu in past trailers
he's lecturing theater on how to pick
his battle also I enjoyed this moment of
the glitching I pieces freaking out
these girls in the tent and Peter was
especially freaky wrapped up in these
outdoor lights which he probably crashed
through they kind of look like those
motion tracking dots that they put on
actors for visual effects mapping and
yeah that behind the scenes footage
always looks pretty terrifying I kill
wherever I like
let's move
hey [ __ ] what are you hiding
Peter
[Music]
I'm just kidding anger bye so this
section here shows more of this
Washington Monument attack which I've
actually dissected in past trailer
breakdown so go check those out but I
like how now the action and the music
suddenly ends in this abrupt jump cut to
Michelle who's a nice character in a
study group demanding to know where
Peters running off to weightless in case
you didn't notice Peters clothes here
kind of tell us when all this action
takes place like check out his I lost an
electron t-shirt it's the same one that
he wears when he meets with Stark and
Avengers HQ so the reason he's running
off is probably because you know
surrogate daddy's calling also this shot
of Peter taking off his tie it's
probably him running out of his
homecoming dance suggesting that that
kiss with lizallen that the other
trailers upended that probably won't
happen ever does it won't last long
there's also a shot from the fairy scene
of this one dude during spider-man on
and notice how the rest of the
passengers are still freaked out and
look at this guy like it's crazy
now again Peter isn't used to this kind
of fan attention so I think this one
cheer will go to his head causing him to
think he can take on these fairy arms
dealers on his own leading into the
vulture showing up and splitting the
fairy in half and an Iron Man needing to
come in and save Peters ass and he asses
of all these innocent bystanders now the
International trailer shows more of this
sequence including this awesome shot of
vulture using his wings to snip
spider-man's webbing so just like the
last trailer when the vulture used his
wings to grab and suspend Peter in the
air it looks like he can use these
things kind of like how Doc Ock used his
claws in spider-man 2 also keep in mind
that Peters webbing is supposed to be
incredibly strong with an estimated
tensile strength of 120 pounds per
square millimeter of cross sections
that's similar to the strength of a
low-end steel cable so vultures wings
being able to cut it here means that
these wind blades must be pretty freakin
sharp okay let's move on to this final
section
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocols because mister
start treat me like a kid you are a kid
you can stop a boss with his bare hands
okay so here in case you couldn't tell
what this was this rubbery texture that
looks like a motherboard is actually the
inside of spider-man's Mac and I love
the detail they design into it and the
fact that Peter has to wear this against
his face now Peter and Ned tried to hack
into the mask and they learn that most
of the features have been lost by Stark
under the training wheels protocol it's
a few things I like about this one just
knowing that this suit has all of these
features seems to be setting up Peter
being able to suddenly use all these
awesome abilities at some point later on
kind of like Chekov spider-man suit but
also Peters whiny reaction here
complaining that start treats him like a
kid well Peters literally jumping up and
down on a bed it's another example of
how this movie parallels Peters suit
with something like a video game it's
like he put in the game and all the best
characters and missions haven't been
unlocked yet and the trailer ends with
some shots of Peter trying to sully this
crashing cargo plane over Manhattan well
it's the International trailer actually
gives us more context for what's going
on here take a look got a Plane full of
brand-new Avengers weaponry to load up
we're gonna put a mother's business
we're going to take everything they got
if you're not gonna stop me
so yeah Sark is shipping weaponry from
Avengers power which to miss plans to
steal mid-flight kind of like Bane and
watch observe flares on this blurred
well if you look closely at this cargo
bay shot those crates have DoD see
written on them Department of damage
control a government branch of this
Avengers battle cleanup operation that
Stark is supplying tech to which Fulcher
plans to steal because that would cut
into a private business well check out
that Iron Man suit in the background
that kind of looks like a mark 42 which
I know it's been confusing because the
mark 42 and all the other previous marks
got destroyed in Iron Man 3 Phil we do
know that Stark just kept building new
Iron Man armor anyway and he'll have new
armor for infinity war so maybe this
suit on the plane it's just some
alternate model that he plans to
transport for storage either way I don't
know if vulture would fit in that Iron
Man suit he's a big guy come on stay out
of this Bane so I'm curious what you
guys think about these trailers and
predamond homecoming specifically these
lingering questions that I still have
one do you think Peters suit is to iron
Manning's like it's kind of an
interesting debate right like it's great
that Iron Man is Spider Man or in a
movie together but is Iron Man's
employed too much like I agree that the
most recent poster was kind of rough
like do you think Iron Man is in there
but really I trust director John watts
and Kevin Feige
and I do think that the stark tech me
video game suit will be a key part of
Peter Parker's growth from teen to adult
and - do you want Marvel to be back in
control of the film rights of all of its
properties like I'm totally with Kevin
Feige when it comes to spider-man and
the Fantastic Four I think both of those
franchises are long overdue for a
homecoming to Marvel but like when it
comes to the x-men I don't know overall
I've been pretty happy with what Fox has
done with the property especially
recently Deadpool and Logan are like two
of the best superhero movies ever and I
just don't know if Marvel would have
allowed those movies to be so
stylistically different and edgy and
r-rated like sure I was bummed that the
x-men weren't part of the Civil War
movie I'm just saying that diversity of
storytelling within a genre can be a
good thing anyway let me know what you
think in the comments and if you like
this video please hit like and subscribe
to new rock stars and if you really like
us you can contribute to us on patreon
thanks
much to all of our current patrons
especially the pony stars you can it
mean up on Twitter a TA box with any
thoughts there series that you have
about spider-man homecoming or follow
new rock stars on Twitter at new rock
stars for updates on our videos ok
thanks for watching bye